est ce que tu es prêt pour l'interview
coq à l'âne
bon alors rédiger de faire une nouvelle
interview oui je m'ai fait à personne je
suis les plâtres ça s'appelle
l'interview calade des prêts au chlore
par exemple est l'homme qui peut deviner
qu'est ce que tu préfères les nuages aux
mains car ce n'est toujours pas toujours
c'est pas nouveau
jusqu'au lennon
c'est jean vincent biarnès et du matin
l'insultent qui t'a fait le plus mal
c'est pas grand
quelque 1,2
l'ascenseur et qui veut passer
les mains sur scène
mais un ticket de métro
johann
est ce que tu as déjà penser autrement
ont déjà pensé à vous
dernière fois
en chantant mam
c'est souvent son pendant
huit coups droits hier à caen champlain
que je sais pas pas plus qu'un
shampooing 2
la recette de la margarita
chacun
le monde
c'est une question d'alcool
on sait quelqu'un me mettre un petit
score
qu'est ce qui était le plus
indispensable autant dormir par terre
la télévision alors content
quelles sont les missions
nous n'avons pas fait qu'elle n'en
soyons c'est ce qu'il ya
les produits
or ce
et le président
je sais pas
seront
ça évite tous
en kippa
grâce à la télé on a tout s'est emballé
après ses prix
yatuu le plus envie d'épater sens l'a10
lamela des cheveux
quel signe tu reconnais infailliblement
l'agouti sur les gens
quel signe
alcool singh
sous représentés
ouais oui
toupet de dire quoi par exemple la toile
tout comme on dit simplement je suis
machin j'arrive de
ouais parce que ça sur l'école
six hommes de tête est ce que je serai
ta fille pas mais là je ne serais pas ma
festival espère et lancia d'heure
je laisserai la liga les catalans
chaussures
non parce que ça c'est s'amuser si on va
plus
c'est plus grave
si c'est pour les rockets
et la question ont toutes celles que je
peux poser kittel plus embarrassé ou de
plus inciter à mentir
c'est quoi chaleur à cette chaleur oui
parce que ça va ensemble puisqu'on
l'allemand est de monter enfin mur d'une
chose et
tout est faux
tout est faux parce que
est-ce que les gens
il sera obligé de penser ça
sont déjà des gens ont terrassé par
d'autres règles
ça c'est bien
est ce que tu préfères léna blou ma
carte mais je peux sans doute pourquoi
j'ai jamais aimé ma carte mais je trouve
on parle comme ça je peux
pâtiront serrar y est un peu petit pour
l'une donne train
non c'est vrai qu'on ouvre enfin chez
seule issue
10 80 pour qu'ils aient le culte eroglu
noël et si possible sortie en mars
meilleur fait ça y est la dernière
personne qui était envie de tuer
j'ai eu à me tuer sabatier quand
ah ouais ah oui parce que c'est un don
de dieu tu préfères les hippies pour les
uk je me suis dit ah bon je préfère le
culte de
les bataves n'ont pas principe amadou
baba je trouve que c'est déjà une
il est forte alors que l'idée schneider
jean est moins intéressant que l'effort
de développer si j'ai développé son
psychisme
très généreux je vais rester à lyon à
tous car avec des couilles juste pas
forcément pas forcément c'est mon
principe c'est un sens
déjà pensé à se suicider oui j'ai pu
sauver les gens
photo
c'était je crois en 81 81 80 points
juste avant
justement que ce n'est pas au rebond tu
disais ça marchera jamais je sais pas
quoi faire de ma vie
j'ai du talent personnes se sont donné
plus lourd
ça c'était un front de mer et jose da de
me sentir complètement inutiles comme ça
c'est une époque je buvais beaucoup
c'était le chaos
vous souhaitez
je ne mets pas du tout j'avais plein de
choses à régler nous y font des
pressions très fortes traitement
j'ai eu envie de sauter par la fenêtre
du huitième étage à l'époque très bien
c'est déjà ce qu'ils soient tapas
regrettable affaire
je pense que tu es capable d'initier
s'améliore ouais est ce que tu crois que
même moi j'ai compati avec le mariage
je pense qu'ils croient pas mais je
pense que parce que j'ai
des caméras n'ont jamais entendu quelque
chose négatif direct sur toi sur moi
je suis trop obscur
fonctions et j'ai tendance à me
dévaloriser trop souvent
or si important c'est la question nous
quand ses qualités ses défauts c'est
entre était fausse modestie à lui seul
de la quatrième session
vie idéale pour une étreinte c'est que
vraiment il n'ya pas de l'unsa tout
n'importe où n'importe quoi pour tous et
et les plus fous à la route a fait
l'amour c'est pas une autre chanson
puisque total mais les gens par le vieux
où tu serais incapable de faire l'amour
partout avec moi tout ce qui peut
arriver
harper c'est facile j'aime autant ne
peut être je crois que c'est vraiment
vraiment il faut choisir
je crois que mccartney en face à celle
influence de jacques je crois que
mccartney mbale autres conventions
on a tout pompé sur l'allemand mais en
tous les cas si ce thonier oui
françoise hardy si je pose la question
comme ça quelle femme est de vous mon
cher jacques chancel jazz résultat est
super fort comme kg comme ont pour une
fois c'est un genre de femmes je dis oui
je vais répondu ça parce que je savais
pas chômé
israël avait dit quelques genres de
femmes minimes j'aurais pu lui dire je
suis une dangereuse aventure hier
quelque chose négative qui dirait sur
toi quelles choses négatives
je tirais
que je vais passer des choses que je
suis passé
confection trop empêtré par notre propre
camp m
je ne peux pas
suffisamment d'efforts quand justement
l'un d'eux
je veux que je te donne un petit peu
trop
ça peut répondre les mrc de d'autray
alors là je sais pas mais il ya pas très
longtemps
certains craignent à quoi reconnaît-on à
saïb l'avoir la bêtise je peux pas
répondre à ça parce que tous des bêtes
et tour sur certains plans et pas sur
deux essais à lui même en général là où
moi je peux être un peu moins bête
cannot et bien je vais beaucoup plus
bêtes que sept autres sur d'autres plans
non mais moi je suis pas le lieu idéal
pour une détresse
moi je suis esclave du confort ce ne
sera donc pas l'ascenseur gave joli
montage a pas tant de faire l'amour tout
va bien
l'objet est la question dans toutes
celles que je viens de te poser qui t'a
le plus incité à mentir
tel que c'est parti la questure sont
l'aboutissement
ce que tu vas faire les nanomatériaux
lynne ley
pourquoi
parce qu'on avait quelque chose de plus
tendres parce que je me sens j'aime bien
sa voix sa douceur j'ai eu l'impression
qu'il avait envie de changer le monde et
qu'il ya donc il a pu être réussi et
puis et puis il est parti trop vite à 27
est aussi passionné parce que tu
préfères séduire ou qu'on va le
convaincre pour une fille c'est paris
porte de versailles
je sais pas fait demander aux hommes
dans quels lieux et eu avec la patte de
faire l'amour quel lieu
bah ici là devant tout le monde avant
elle s'en va dans un film ça n'arrive à
ses bras
un personnage à bord on ne fait pas
l'amour en vrai donc si j'ai déjà c'est
déjà ses dessins et on fait des produits
chez devred aisée pour autant la part de
gâteau autant cela prenne puisque l'on
en a le droit
c'est donc ce états unis
mission ou alors j'ai pas comme ça je ne
vais pas avoir une once et les autres
jours d'avoir voulu mourir pas se dire
que maintenant avec un enfant ça
m'effraie mais quoi donc je sais qu'on a
plus le droit de votre vie
mi temps il ya 80 ans 80
et
parce qu'à un moment donné la vie elle
te parallèle te file entre les doigts et
et au lieu de s'en tire la couverte de
cela tu n'as sans même plus peut-être
qu'à un moment donné la feuille d'érable
tu as fais quoi moi je voulu passer de
l'autre côté là on va pas les mêmes
couleurs notamment mais ça va sur
descendu c'est en même temps qu'est ce
que j'ai voulu me pendre c'était une
bibliothèque et dont le système est et
s'est écroulé donc c'est en même temps
et c'est justement par le rite ou bien
sûr vous allez un truc c'est très à
l'aise quand même terrible on tient ses
magazines du monde que moi c'est trop
tard c'est pas pour moi
passé un certain âge a précédé c'est
plus dur qu elle est en insultant
préfère va mourir d'amour r
tu la dit quand on l'a souvent moins
longtemps je n'ai pas vu génère pas trop
là ça va tu veux tuer personne
non je suis pas quelqu'un qui marche
dans les rapports de force je déteste ça
et quand il ya un rapport de france même
on va essayer d'en parler on va essayer
de se retrouver mais c'est comme ça nous
associons et quel est pour toi aussi à
vapeur de la passion naissante à regard
quelque chose à l'intérieur du ventre
que t'arrives pas à maîtriser plus
et puis puis celle à quoi ces derniers
souvent non ça n'arrive pas souvent
ça fait quand même froid dans l'avion
foire
et la passion qui s'étale ce sera comme
un set
la passion qui s'éteint
pour moi est évoquée par un choc par
quelque chose un jour qu'ils fassent
rire le break 4
mais bon maintenant je suis en a eu
l'info énormément parce que j'aime une
capacité d'aimer puis j'aime j'aime les
gens j'aime les amis je les amis de
jésus et puis depuis 25 ans parce que je
préviens je dis attention mayam là
cliquez sur payet son attention il faut
il faut il faut voir pas tuer avec quad
magath est sur toi
zhu que
il faut que j'arrête de pouvoir
peut-être trop de convaincre voilà
plusieurs blessés venir la plus grave il
s'est pas à temps je sais pas non plus
grande anse
[Musique]
à parler peut-être le plus indispensable
pour s'endormir au l'idéal c'est le
canard l'idéal c'est simple je m'en sens
capable
bah oui
enfin c'est ça oui je trouve ça vous
c'est lui
c'est parfait c'est quoi dans toutes les
questions ont été posées celle qui était
le plus embarrassé
hambach et celio j'ai eu du mal à
trouver la profondeur du terrain c'était
avant-hier c'est là qu'elle a ni
nous détestons mensonge gilles a pas
menti je déteste ça laissait
teint orange après ministère il secret
mais le mensonge demandai je
je sais pas faire j'aimais qui s'annonce
toujours plus de sa voix et musiques du
martray
j'essaye dommage puisque je ne sais pas
mentir je suis contente et essayer ici
c'est ça aussi c'est parler vrai quoi
aller interview coq à l'âne voilà
marianne basler bonsoir alors imagine
quand on se rend compte comme ça tous
les deux ans une fois tout soit si tu me
dis avec quoi si tu avais envie de me
répondre si je t'ai abordait je
définirais comme en faveur des mre en
devenir
je reste 4 ailes enfin un fou je
l'assuré mystérieuse on sait pas grand
chose de toi j'ai commencé le théâtre à
13 ans et à 10 pour le détail y'a pas le
feu au lac quoi t'as pas envie d'être
travaillée d'être une actrice mais pas
une star alors ben si je me souviens
parfaitement c'est pas vraiment ça mon
choix c'est pas en france après quoi un
petit arrangement de plus tard le
rendement est très discrète
normal souveraine dans sa filmographie
tu as fais plein de films en fait mais
tu di rosa la rose noces barbares
outre-mer leur temps à fait plein
d'autres pourquoi tu décides pas les
autres disons que c'est ce que je tente
plus c'est encore aux ars était mon
premier choix mais très peu tabou et
avec qui jean pierre mas cané prochaine
la réalisatrice ajoute yann roudeilla ce
barça est aussi de très belles
rencontres et autres mars amateurs
aussi quand j'étais gamin ne sachant pas
le moins partagés j'y tiens maintenant
trois hommes et un couffin au passage
150 le boeuf non c'était
tu me rends
j'avoue
quant à elle parcourt
je suis en panne mince et très discrète
sur sa vie privée aussi bas salaires que
moi j'attaque tout cas ce qu'ont annoncé
les choses quand même on les arrache par
mois mais à l'amour comme ça actu retour
des beaux jours
j'ai lu qu'il avait pu je préfère mais
j'estime plus en belgique où elle avait
une bouche pas toujours le même depuis
l'âge de 15 ans
oui cette mesure
c'est lui qui vient maintenant oui quel
appareil de mise au pas du tout pas du
tout c'est vraiment ils ont trois points
cette semaine
alors ça se passe comment ça se passait
très bien mais vous attrape ses instrus
celui qui gère tout ça c'est une super
pradinas selim et rencontrer ces
libelles et sûrement même silence ça se
plaint de tram ces domaines c'est une
femme qui aime mmmm qu'il aime d'une
façon un peu un peu tourmenté un peu
exclusive qui
c'est même quelque part avec quatre
représentants de ce qu'ils veulent on ne
peut pas être autrement le poteau pour
entretenir c'est amer il superpose c'est
un histoire d'amour et de déchirement ce
saut
deux personnes
bouffées reims ça ne veut pas
ça vous parle
occupons nous sommes tous pareils et
basse parents de vider les transports et
les connaît on a passé un amour
impossible
mais peut-être que après vont se
retrouver
ce sera très bien comme ça c'est un
texte ça je joue brûlures aux mains
alors tout sur moi qui s'attaque à la
retraite
tu peux faire de la nouvelle carte mais
je ne savais pas le lieu idéal pour une
étreinte en page 3 le pacte est idéale
de minceur sas et tous les trains qui
compte que le bout des doigts par tous
les moyens que le train des duels je
crois que noël ça je vis est incapable
de faire l'amour
je ne sais pas du tout je perds souvent
l'adhérence acquis par s était installé
mais dans la vie
on sera très longtemps puisque c'est
vers la mort non pas d'amour
même si j'en avais je parle c'est pas
chez toi le signe avant-coureur de la
passion descente une différence d'une
certaine façon c'est passé comme ça avec
le pour jeunes en belgique
je ne suis pas invité ces petites jamais
arrivé depuis par ces jeunes mais plutôt
de la brousse depuis déjà 10 ans je ne
sais pas peut-être est le signe de la
passion qui s'est a déjà deux
américaines de la boussole je ne sais
pas c'était temps
s'interroge un autre sage donc par
million de personnes
nous avons tué 31
j'aimerais bien être entendu
et la dernière personne que tu ai eu
envie de tuer ma milk bonne réponse
l'insultent qui t'a fait le plus mal
tellement je sais pas
je sais pas qu'est ce que tu as depuis
sexy et tomasi emploi à mon derrière
ah bon je sais pas si les autres quelque
chose négative tu dirais surtout il
fallait vraiment tu te dise du mal de
toi disent du mal de matches et que je
suis pas assez exigeante avec moins de
rage
tu pense qu'au cinéma le problème que tu
as eue c'était parce que tu as il
exigerait que j'ai pas assez confiance
pour que j'aurais dû faire plus
confiance à autre chose que je sais que
mon avis c'est vrai qu'on a parlé des
fois de sa désinvolture qui pense que tu
es trop désinvolte
moi j'étais trop détaché parce que
souvent choisi les choses sans y croire
parce que je savais bien qu'on pouvait
faire mieux
c'était comme ça alors j'avais mené san
fermin fait qu'elle cible par les colts
owner assure moi c'est un miracle
le lieu idéal pour une étrave année pour
être le lieu où tu en es capable de
faire la montre l'endroit les escaliers
sacha la dictature
nous sommes dix mois est la durée chez
toi le signe avant-coureur de la passion
naissante
votre désarroi fallait déséquilibre
commander officielle pour les la passion
que c'est ça la lassitude quoi j'arrive
à bien plus tôt qui a écrit une chanson
qui le maintient de moi qui prends sec
et très chaud idées j'en ai marre de toi
comme ça tu préfères la draguer ou
draguer
les recherches sur google est votre ami
par quelqu'un qu'on a envie draguer les
voix tu être opéré je voudrais brûlés ah
bon soit qu'ils s'en soient éparpillés
dans l'ombre ses côtés 1,12 quelle est
la question
pour toutes celles que j'ai des projets
la quitta le plus à cette affaire ne
sors pas mon team s'est pas répondu à
une seule question des relations étaient
à oui je sais c'est en libye
c'est un mec qui m'a traité une fois de
monde allemand goethe eu la grâce qu'il
était tôt déjà c'est sympa et puis après
ça j'étais une oie évadés du couvent
deux jours sur ce sur quoi je dois ça
gentil aussi ça agréable
ça arrive souvent les choses agréables
je crois qu'il faut il faut en rire toi
c'est hervé le voilà la foule est ce que
tu t'es plus en plus
ascione qui t'a fait le plus mal contre
les gros tatouage a bon dos quand
j'étais mannequin
j'avais près toujours qu'un centimètre
de moins que les autres j'étais un peu
grand port de monde
qu'est ce que tu as le plus sexy on doit
condamner on m'a dit de sourcier sur
cindy quat'sous sa maman
ce qui était le plus indispensable pour
t'endormir manu à sonny cher président à
new york le téléphone ses dires de
damien battu le plus cher vie de taper
dans la vie
[Musique]
ma mère j'ai toujours mal maintenant tu
les fais ça va je crois mais les
tribunes
sam et la martyre elle connaît sting
peter gabriel d'averses que lipitor
quelque chose négative tout direct sur
toi
oh
je suis pas assez relax jeune alice coup
métro disons que j'ai je crois que la
très bonne analyse mais après mon esprit
de synthèse dont une fatale il a été
fait c'est le lien idéal pour une
étrange les bras mais bioware mouvement
qui avaient bravé je suis très brave
quand est-ce que tu as pleuré pour la
dernière fois
avant-hier qui peut souvent sortant de
scène sur les glaces se suicider
ouais ouais c'est bien c'est très bon
public
et quand manu sera ce truc là aussi non
oui il faut surtout pas que nous nous
signe avant-coureur de la passion
naissante il doit toutefois c
pour moi tomber amoureux c'est
c'est discerner une personne parmi eux
c'est ne pas pouvoir détacher ses yeux
de la passion qui se tapent faire
l'amour plus faire la bombe je crois que
c'est vraiment ce qui est plus
importante
tu préfères à breguet ou est dragué en
général c'est le jeune je ne drague pas
c'est pas le nommer
en fait les zones qui m'ont attiré en
général sont des hommes qui drague pas
du tout donc effectivement c'est plutôt
moi qui fais
c'est très café pas besoin du pôle
notamment de tamanu c'est moi il attendu
six ans quand même je crois que j'ai pas
fait le premier pager imaging ça fait
six ans que j'attends c'est l'argent
pour toi là oui je te revoir 200 francs
2,5 fois c'est vrai
oui
vous m'avez vous
m
on va comparer les réponses avec la la
fois d'avant qu'un qui tu me fais penser
à monsieur de fursac mois
aurais tu es l'homme geos a pu les
abîmer
bon monsieur défense ak bravo à wanda
jackson
bilan
à nos couleurs
jamais on n'a vu du jour mais je me
souviens je préviens la chaîne que je ne
suis pas sûr d'arriver au bout de cette
émission et c'est la première fois que
je ressens cela il a craqué john carew
jacques aillagon avait son petit
continent
et heureusement je vais rendre dans les
centres de puissants drôle lorsque la
pluie s'est invitée mal qu'il a fait aux
gens ils adorent cela
excusez moi ce qui se voit calme-toi par
le corps est découvert
si je vous demandais ya dix ans qu'elle
est à l'époque tutoyer le genre tutoie
pas moi je vous disais qu'est les
insultes qui t'a fait le plus mal tu et
arras ont ils répondu quoi servent trip
hop on veut éviter est fait comme ça
j'ai entendu ce qu'il a dit ramzy
à l'oratoire déranger
bon donc il ya dix ans je devoir de la
sophie duez quelle est l'insulté qui t'a
fait le plus mal si vous posez la
question aujourd'hui - pendriez quoi
voir si c'est la même je crois que
c'était frappadingue non ribouldingue
non grosse vache non vous n'êtes pas
loin
grosse truie non moi je mâche navet
tentant oui oui je pense que ça sur
question je suis toujours un petit
boudin non la grosse sauvage lagos dans
un gros boudin non j'étais gros tas bon
vous disiez parce que j'avais quinze
centimètres de moi et les autres j'étais
un peu en dedans quand je vous disais
qu'est ce que tu as à l'époque tutoyer
qu'est ce que tu as de plus sexy en toi
et vous me répondiez non vous avez
répondu les sourcils à l'époque de
société qu'est ce qui vous est le plus
indispensable pour vous endormir
c'est pas très sexy des sourcils enfin
c'est ce qu'elle disait
figure toi que lorsque tu vois à quel
point ça fait peur à beaucoup d'hommes a
beaucoup de metteurs en scène et
sourcils ah oui on m'a demandé mille
fois des piles et mes sourcils quoi
pourtant des poils et que ça fait peur
donc je suis sûr qu'il ya un vote gens
n'avaient jusque-là mène à des pompages
et l école à l'achat ce qui m'a sauvé
c'est brooke shield qui est arrivé qu'a
lancé la mode des grandes forces jamais
de plus indispensable avant de vous
endormir
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui bon petit coup
de dés amorce d amorçage panne on attend
déjà les désamorcer certaines d'aller
respirer l'élégance on doit mieux de mes
deux petites filles vont accoucher
voilà à l'époque c'était de manu et bal
à la suite voilà maintenant c'est les
enfants la chance le lieu idéal pour une
étreinte un plateau de télé à l'époque
vous aviez répondu les bras je suis très
bravo m'aviez dit tu peux expliquer
comment tu aimeras je te pose est
comment les bras alors si tu veux entre
entre les bras là il ya une place moi
j'ai pas le temps
c'est une bête moyens contre 8,6 et
animations tu m'as fait très vite pensé
que j'étais tanné la bonne génération
voilà c'était toute une aile sophie
sophie duez est une femme du xviiie
siècle
ça ne veut pas le savoir 18e à paris
alors un époque que j'ai demandé à
sophie duez à quoi reconnait tue la
passion qui s'éteint et vous me
répondriez aujourd'hui je vais vous dire
vous vous disiez à l'époque on fait plus
l'amour
ouais moi toute façon je pense que quand
il n'y a plus assez de temps je pense
que non mais franchement gênant parce
que au départ je me disais si un homme
veut coucher avec une fille c'est qu'ils
aiment pas ils étaient intéressés que
par que que par que moi le dire que par
ça mais en fait j'ai compris en vivant
au contraire c
ces preuves que le couple peut exister
si elle ce désir là il faut pas en avoir
peur
dans le conflit certaines filles ont été
retenues quelques comme ça on te dit
temps si l'homme items il en affiche de
ça c'est pas vrai que ça c'est qu'il ya
un problème
voilà d'accord moi j'ai moi
personnellement j'ai jamais fait l'amour
mais en tout cas je sais que quand ça je
les fais cette fois je souhaite
j'attends la bonne foi j'ai la bonne
personne mais j'attends encore mais les
trios titre c'est jean michel jean
michel d'euzet le michel une fille à
l'époque je demandais à idron pas eric
et ramzy blavou est-ce que vous
préfériez vous est ce que tu préfères te
faire parce qu'il préfère à rien sauf à
se faire draguer on aime draguer et vous
me disiez à l'époque je pense que vous
ne voyez la même chose aujourd'hui les
hommes qui m'attire ne drague pas donc
j'ai obligé de faire le premier pas moi
j'ai une phrase pour ça c'est tout ce
qui me prennent la tête je les jette
excusez-nous sophie mais je préfère le
climat qui a maintenant en tout cas
j'aime bien ton prénom me rappelle quand
même un canal famille verra pas d'abord
way un canal de dieu et du de la ferme
et les montagnes le mental du snjv
mais j'aime aussi les montagnes au ccfd
- terre battue
on va rallumer la lumière la passe est
tout trouvé un bac de l'acte
un style qui t'a fait le plus mal dans
ta musique est quelqu'un qui m'a dit je
n'ai pas deux visages pas de peur 4 ch
n'est pas trop sociaux
c'est bien gentil mais s'était pas
révélé aussi la vidéo
monsieur geoffrey ya exactement trois
ans parfois ça je crois que c'était très
vite c'est plus sexy re en toi à ton
avis quelque chose négatif tu dirais sur
toi
à 7h02 abondé trouver le lien idéal pour
l'une et râble chez toi non mais en fait
je sais gré ce jour j'avais une famille
je crois précédera de ces partis peu
avant tout génial
le lion est incapable de faire l'amour
je pense aux éditions bref ici là pas
bien ça aussi c'était dû s'éclater
quand je leur ai pleuré pour la dernière
fois
on peut même pas très longtemps parce
que j'adore ce que tu peux faire séduire
convaincre
merci fait mettre le web a dû être
enterré j'ai longtemps tu aimerais pas
votre collègue en foot à bord et qu'on
mette échangeront sur tour mag
ching la musique forte houle et joan
ferran ficelles tu peux faire draguer
les mecs web drague d abord parce que ça
tu as eu des expériences comme ça de
distance à la drogue et différence comme
sa prime tout de suite là à bon oui sur
des plates formes mais parce que l'étape
tout mon truc comme ça j'ai déjà pensé
au suicide
oui
est-ce qui est un métier qui tue
regrette de ne pas avoir exercé par ce
qu'ils font mais c'est vrai c'est vrai
je suis fasciné par l'écolo recycler sa
rue je suis fasciné par fasciné par les
champions j'aurais aimé être champion
quand on sait que les succès puisque
déjà plus difficile car le tour de
france c'est parce que tu tes vacances
en allemagne
non ces dernières peuvent toujours pas
tu sais que tu vas et viens tu vois ils
veulent monte avait résonné on commence
à sentir ce soit chez un visionnaire
attend de ce que la dernière fois après
l'émission j'ai une lettre d'une
journaliste de stern raison monsieur
c'est votre émission d'ardisson et on ne
peut pas véhiculer des images aussi
rétrograde cascades - qu'est-ce qu'ils
apprennent tout ça ça n'existe plus
votre pays les allemands ont changé les
jeunes allemands sont des gens comme
vous démarrez et puis sur ce drame et
soudan matin se tenait sous la torture
qui des deux structures en premier par
lagerfeld sous la tour à jean moulin
avait déjà - est-ce que tu concerne le
ferons pas que tu refuse de dévoiler
oui certainement décider
gg
j'ai été élevé avec une
des pleurs qui est tout à fait dépasser
certainement mais je me retiens tout
l'indispensable quand on leur mit un
appart nstar jamais ce travail car tu as
dit je trouve ça très bien tu t'es tiré
après une nuit dans ce qui est divisée
je ne prends jamais rien pendant la
longue balle et j'ai tout comme tu bosse
tous les jours ce qui est bon j'avais
jamais rien
11h12 - port est moi je te dis je sais
pas depuis que le grand défi qui
n'existait plus et je cherche ailleurs
quelque chose de négatif sur toi parce
que tout le monde ait toujours des trucs
positifs sans quoi toute la journée
ce que je suis très superficielle que la
force de vie comme ça de survoler de
mener je fais que papillonner c'est vrai
que je pensais que si je te disais tout
à l'heure le
on est quel sport fr je te disais
coureur cycliste
parce que ça veut dire se concentrer sur
une chose et la faire jusqu'au bout
jusqu'au bout là je joue souvent sur des
facilités sur des
sur un survol à très très léger des
choses qui fait sérieusement les choses
super qu'il serait absolument les gens
se saluent échéant gens sont l'ennemi
c'est vrai tu es français
j'aimerais tempéré je crois qu un des
plus beaux endroits au pays basque
ouais et j'ai maintenant on essaie de
faire entrer dans les séries c'était
obligatoire à quel s'il reconnais tu as
failli blement la béquille sujet
[Musique]
on était censé l'être dans toutes les
questions je te poser la question d'une
telle hausse quelle est celle dite a
incité à mentir vas tu as parfaitement
ce n'est pas parce qu'on est seulement
parce que
parce que je vais te raconter quoi s'est
dit des choses que par pudeur naturelle
j'aime ça passe dans l'écriture
s'adresse dans le
cependant une autre expression et de
dire les choses comme ça va être même
faire [ __ ] padoue sénégalais
résidant bon ben je fais un peu
d'interviews coq à l'âne tu es d'accord
d'accord
est-ce que tu préférerais être coq aux
ânes bombe à faire cote parce que mon
bar monter quand même
ainsi déjà pensé au suicide bomber un
bon équipement demandée par nombre a pas
écrire non maquillée
est-ce que tu m'aimes bon bah page à
tête qui devance reçu en premier sous la
torture
danic n'aura qu'à victoire à granby bon
parfum
tu crois qu'il faut coucher pour réussir
dans bas même m'a toujours réussir à
coucher
est-ce qu'il faut des capotes pour
toucher bomba bombe a toujours le dépôt
sur banane ouais tu viens on va se
baigner patricia tous était de 2h40
moi bon bah c'est pas bien d'être devenu
star au moment du sida obama peut se
raconter femelle grands singes verts
femelle grands singes verts tableau
quelle est la dernière personne que tu
fais une envie de tuer
christophe lambert par son opération
non j'en passe trop vite
encore inconnue tue la passion naissante
bamba campagne bombe a sauvé tout seul
et la personne visée sa campagne
montbard venir case départ ils habitent
ici reconnaît à quoi bon bah langage
prétention certains animateurs
mais ce que vous a fait le plus mal que
j'avais
quatre ans
mr fois que j'entendais un truc agressif
ouais on a pu lire
format
et la cgt un révolté c'est la première
fois que que quelqu'un était méchant
jusqu'à cet âge là comme on a été
gentils mais tu as découvert voilà voilà
voilà première fois il se rend compte de
la misère et la gestuelle est pour toi
est ce que tu as déjà pensé au suicide
j'espère que ces parts à ce moment là
ouais j'y pense pourtant tout le temps
tout c'est pourquoi depuis pas le
courage et acura je finirai bezina il ya
une vraie logique c'est un palliatif
mais c'est vrai que j'y pense depuis
depuis l'âge de 13 14 ans elle a accepté
le revers de la médaille
mais bon d'un autre côté je sais par
quoi il s'était plutôt une question
et puis ça dure ça guérif avions
connaissent un petit peu alors mal est
fait si ce n est pour toi la suivante
comme chou sexisme en réponse officielle
à vous faire dresser les méchantes que
c'est depuis section doit donner vie et
silence
qu'est ce qui vous a le plus
indispensable pour vous endormir
sûrement pas auteur seulement de toute
façon indispensable du normal c'est
humain cette histoire le drame c'est ça
tu t'appelles devra jusqu'ici dans le
top-10
alors quelque chose négative qu'il y
aurait sur toile
je pense que je m'en du ministère ah bon
et gentil non
enfin je pense que j'ai mon des
musiciens parce que l'idéal pour une
étrave avant d'y voir une question comme
celle ci ici on ne sait pas tellement
plus alors dans la rue dans la rubrique
idées à cause de toi
voilà ça sur cinq gagne en visibilité
plus en un c'est la rue l'autre céline
loewe ou parole vous êtes incapable de
faire l'amour je veux vraiment grotte
non non non ça je suis moi même si déjà
mis cimetière non et toi je crois pas il
n'y a pas d'endroit les maisons
abandonnées dans l'aisne dans les trains
fréquenté ouais non je cause n'auriez
pas l'endroit désagréable quand tu as
pleuré pour la dernière fois
ah bon vous pouvez ensuite hissé à la
télé le signe avant-coureur de la
passion naissante
je suis au courant de son outil puissant
mon coeur qui bat de la passion qui
s'est tu as besoin là je pense aussi que
les manies des autres bien sûr pour
femmes
je pense que ces moments par exemple
pour étoffer la bouche un hommage à quoi
on peut tout en devient presque un
sentiment de claustrophobie là je pense
que c'est le début de la fin il ya une
vanille suppression de la dette
quelle est la question la coupe seule
touche je vous le disais que les autres
composés qui vous a le plus excité à m
ce n'est pas moi de présenter son frère
alors c'est quoi pour toi dit de nous
mais à a
je pense que j'exagère parce que un peu
trop parce que je n'achète pas niveau
des jambes je suis principalement porte
à faux et je me retrouve en défaut de
fumer c'est moi qui les a menacés parce
que tu as mangé une salade du satan a
réussi je n'ai pas menti
tapez amandine on jette dur
ce tu peux faire ce que tu préfères être
un coq ou annan tu avais le choix est
haché entre un coquin et transformer
encore raté un coq n'a pas décidé à
lausanne d'accord qu est le surnom qu'on
te donne que tu es le plus que tu
détestes le puits femmes garçons vincent
s'est passé non pas si c'est vrai que
j'ai détesté les poupées que j'aimais
bien je n'ai pas joué au kitsch n'est
que j'adorais jouer avec les garçons et
c'est pas de forme parce que tu étais
avant le 10 et 4 patrie parce que je
n'avais aucune baisse arrivé tard comme
ça quand 16 ans mais là ça va
est-ce que tu passerais tes vacances au
bail
on peut pas chasser un attentat parce
que tu as un truc spécial pour réussir
la farine non je ne sais pas qui tu sais
pas faire là bas il y avait rien du tout
vous dire que j'évoque c'est lui qui
cuisinent à c'est lui qui a bien fait
les choses et français autour et cie
france est attachée lui son truc c'était
tout j'avais tissés ya d'autres corps de
kelvin
quelle est l'insulté dans ta vie qui t'a
fait le plus mal pourtant non non non je
suis en train de penser à quelque chose
de triste et filles c est l est
el kolla triste hiver est oui j'avais
tué quelqu'un
si malines fils un sens ça fait de la
peine là oui parce que je suis quelqu'un
à bord aussi avant coureurs de la
passion de descente à quoi tu sens tulle
être amoureuse avait déjà l'estomac à
l'estomac ouais c'est là le plexus le
plexus mais depuis ce temps c'était
pareil et je peux pas faire un jeu
partout ce club c'est bien le coup à
l'estomac
non à l'estomac non quel est le lieu
idéal pour une trace pris comme une
étreinte pour faire l'amour le vieux et
doivent s'habituer à 6 pour la chanson
la table c'est pas été atteints
n'avaient pas dire que en moins
donnée comme la folie prix jour ça
arrive mais tu as i talent du tout prêt
quand même tu finis dames 1 c'est quand
même émission le roi tu vois si c'est
sur la moquette a toujours mal au genou
tu as si c'est comme ça tu finis il peut
bien il faut qu'ils soient très
costaudes alors bon tu vois ça ça glisse
à sa tombe
nous avons peut-être laissé à même de la
draft pour le lieu est incapable de
faire l'amour temps incapable
l'endroit où s'est pas beaucoup mais
c'est pas la moquette est très mal la
consigne c'est quoi consignes et
astrologie cancer et si c'est pas bon
j'ai lu mon ascendance
sinon je suis de mon copain m'a fait
jusqu'à que je trouve un qui est bon
j'aimerais être enterrés ou à ce moment
là je serais morte tout temps fou
n'importe où même en france
quelle est la question dans toutes
celles que je vais proposer qui t'a le
plus incité à mentir
j'ai peut-être et menteuse aujourd'hui
non pas pourquoi
qu'est ce qu'on va faire là non pas du
coq à l'âne coq à l'âne ouais on dit ça
te va
mais pourquoi succès vers ce que j'ai
vécu ce soir tu préfères francophone à
la coque
pourquoi et bassecourt monde est
toujours monté comme un âne brillant
comme un coq
est ce que tu as déjà pensé au suicide
ouais quand bahia moi je me suis dit
qu'il fallait que j'approuve tout ce que
j'ai insulté ce soir parce que tu es le
plus sexy en toi
la merde à l'éclair veut et de moins
sexy il avait jeu est ce que tu peux
aller passer des vacances en allemagne
ouais même sans problème un art mais si
vous voulez tortures qu'ils
dénonceraient qui en premier pardon sous
la torture qui dénonceraient tu en
premier si je dois sauver ma peau
1 tous parce que mes parents ils
voudraient pas me voir mourir donc si je
les dénonce ils seront contents mes amis
si c'est des amis c'est pareil est ce
que j'aime pas tant pis pour
est ce que tu pourrais poussé à
hurlements maintenant là
et c'est bien là tu crois qu'il faut
coucher pour réussir
moi je croyais ça parce que j'ai fait ce
métier pour ça et je travaille et je
couche pas
dis moi patrick sérieusement mais j'ai
toujours voté cet amendement c'est à
dire d'être devenu une star au moment du
sida dont une star au moment du sida au
moment du sida je voudrais plus connus
dire le sida on s'en débarrasse
quelle est la dernière personne qui
était j'ai envie de tuer qui est des
fois quand je regarde des personnes je
me dis l'avortement
ça pourrait avoir lieu et ça devrait
être légal même 65 ans après l'aisne
alors qu'elle faisait un tabou coq à
l'âne êtes près tous les deux je sais
pas je pense que ça va dit bah tiens par
exemple ce que tu as de plus sexy en toi
vincent
enfin ce qui se voit permanences qui se
voit pas gctat les commentaires je
revenais pas d'avoir mouscron ce que tu
as de moins sexy en toi
ben je sais pas tout le reste
pourquoi dire ça voilà un truc
fonctionne bien que trop vrai que ça me
pousse mais je vois c'est même sur un
peu boudiné comme ça ah bon ce n'est pas
fini c'est ça c'est ce qu'on disait
quelque chose négative tu dirais sur toi
sur moi-même vrai si tu voulais te
casser le cas c est tout faire du mal à
chaud pop je suis sans grand intérêt
je mangerai pas tu as eue sur moi oui
c'est moi ou en tout cas ne crois pas du
tout à tuer jeanne camps suicide
s'agissant enfin des femmes ont pu
présenter sa part a notamment fait 13
ans et 57 chez tous ouais je vais faire
un bon garçon
et alors
où il habitait et puis une voiture qui
arrive et puis je suis allé j'y suis
allé rencontrer la voiture car même à
renverser et je me suis je me suis je
suis tombé quoi c'est un mec m'a vous me
cherchez verdelhan c'est vrai maintenant
ça va tu m avais à draguer comme un
malade
c'était un bien qui en bus étaient déjà
tombés du trapèze la figure sur le tapis
encore tu t'es fait renverser par la
manivelle
voilà c'est moi je me suis permis à la
chine 7 ce kit est le plus indispensable
pourtant leur meilleur au bout c'est
quoi tes d'où ces deux vieux t-shirt
dégueulasse
alors qu'ils étaient blancs au départ
moins deux morts
on est
maintenant on va se régaler son père qui
a tu le plus envie d'épater
si j'étais frange dire à moi quand tu
pleurais pour la dernière fois
on y apprend aussi à rien et on en
parlait hier soir je suis sûr j'ai fait
les frais en ti au centenaire de la
scène et ouais vraiment de faire un
inventaire parce que je sais pas le jeu
suivant à quoi reconnaît-on est
faiblement la bêtise fadam l'assurance
avec laquelle s exprime généralement
c'est vrai
la dernière personne que tu as envie de
tuer qu'est-ce qui se passerait à munich
qu est ce qu un effet d'image
y'a plus d'image la plus de 100 ya plus
rien n'avait bougé un cil bon c'est vrai
bien la cause dans le coup d'état
ça va tu es content jusque là ça voilà
je sais pas moi ouais ça va je trouve un
peu coincé là non ça va très bien c'est
à dire que j'étais une émission de télé
tu vois donc c'est un psychanalyste plus
loquace mais bon là je fais quand la
tension
j'ai mes parents qui regarde le temps
d'aller tous ceux qui ont toujours rien
jouant sa manière de presse
s'il entend par là j'ai pas touché les
intrus vasini toujours je suis très bien
ma femme et mes enfants pour toi c'est
quand même mangé un morceau a pas
d'émission ben oui mais à condition que
ce ne soit pas le tien quoi
on va faire quelques questions un peu
plus difficile on va faire une interview
coq à l'âne vous êtes prêts oui alors
est-ce que vous préféreriez être un coq
ou a même un âne parce que les anons
certaine réputation
ils venaient de plus sexy en vous
montgri grimace amaigri et de moi un
sexy montgré gris quand
le percepteur est passé vous écrivez
quoi quand on vous demande des
autographes
n'importe quoi souvent michel drucker
ouais
et les gens sont beaucoup plus content
que si j'avais signé de nombreux noms
est ce que est ce que vous vous aimez
pas du tout pourquoi mais parce que je
prends j'aurais voulu je n'ai pas être
un mas grands
brun un peu comme on dit les enfants
n'ont pas vu quoique adam khan a mis sur
la table ou coq à l'âne c'est des
questions qui fait du coq à l'âne
qu'elle et les insultes qui t'a fait le
plus mal dans ta vie lorsqu'on m'a cru
idiote stupide
c'est un constat ça c'est pas du tout
monsieur 9e des risques sévères
un genou je me demande pardon la
mairesse je m'excuse je ne ferai plus
oh
a pensé au suicide oui quant à disons
que très souvent je pense que je vais
programmé ma mort c'est moi qui l'a
programmerait tu écris quoi quand on me
demande des autographes
c'est banal j'ai créé bisous le va
développer
est-ce que tu m'aimes moi oui je t'aime
beaucoup beaucoup oui
jusqu'à quel point je te connais pas
intimement j'aime tant d'intelligence et
puis se trouve que tu est hyper
séduisant parce que tu ressembles à
prêtre
sous la torture qui dénonceraient tu en
premier un contrat tu crois qu'il faut
coucher pour réussir non seulement pas
c'est pas la peine non
comment ça peut te coucher ne pas
réussir
c'est par année quand as tu pleurais
fait monter le dimanche on savait que le
divin
est ce que j'ai fait
jay leno toi tu pleures pour la dernière
fois
pour la dernière fois lorsque j'ai perdu
un ami
aimerais-tu être enterré dans le petit
village je suis né quelle est la
dernière personne que tu ai eu envie de
tuer de tuer sa fille c'est vrai que
c'est tentant
c'est tentant non j'adore est ce que tu
pourrais faire draguer ou de faire
varier
j'aime bien me faire draguer
et donner l'impression d'ignorer cette
avance était super tu préfères leur vie
ou de faire larguer ont argué évidemment
à quoi reconnaît-on infailliblement la
passion naissante chez un mec on regarde
que fais-tu si tu as besoin de
téléphoner dans la rue tu n'as pas de
mener étapes et les cartes évident que
fais tu ici toujours mon téléphone
portatif shebab ont donc t'as pas besoin
de télé car étant d'accord est-ce que tu
préfèrerais être un coq aux ânes qui
prescrit foncel les invités passaient
une petite culotte et une pierre
coq l'insultent qui t'a fait le plus mal
l'insu khimki par exemple pourra me
faire le plus beau des compliments
venant de toi
ouais bon séjour luis tejada quand ben
voilà non les compliments quand ils sont
pas sincères c'est comme une insulte à
l'intégrité 10 mois est ce que tu as
déjà pensé au suicide
ok environnement espérant provoquer
c'est bien sûr par amour mais là j'ai
envie de jouer envie de répondre un peu
plus gravement d'extrapoler en fait
tiens j'ai envie de te dire que quand tu
es amoureux tu conçois des châteaux en
espagne m'ajuster mois notamment en
espagnol samedi
la même façon puis toute la salle un peu
n'est ce pas bâché
départ de la salle est entré il est con
parce que tu es tout ce qui est
maintenant sa penderie pas vraiment
pourquoi cette c'est le choix tu attires
borne basse
qu'est-ce que tu es le plus sexy emploi
ont mangé un petit arrêt oui il parait
ma bouche
c'est vrai et de moins c'est que c'est
être sexy en fait c'est s'est dégagé
comme c'est une espèce d'électricité de
magnétisme être réceptif aux autres et
quand soudain as tu deviens plus que
cérébral et non mais c'est adam fois
qu'est ce que tu es trop compliqué
sans compter deux ans déjà en écoute
alors là vraiment ça dépend de la
personne du contexte
et puis de mon humeur je m'adapte est-ce
que tu m'aimes oui moi non plus d'accord
est-ce qu'il faut coucher pour réussir
ah bah non la preuve qu est ce que je
suis là on peut faire ça deux bouts ou
sinon vous voudrez tut marié où je
voudrais me marier il faudrait d'abord
que tu me poses la question voudrais tu
te marier
je suis sûr que tu vas pouvoir te marier
à un moment où je voudrais me marier en
provence ah bon tallinn maurice non les
corrections de nourrir raté de l'inédit
tube abonnez vous il mettait un coup de
boule